cloudy climate change how clouds affect
Earth's temperature
Earth's average surface temperature has
warmed by 0.8 Celsius since 1750 when
calm dioxide concentrations in the
atmosphere have doubled which is
expected before the end of the 21st
century researchers project global
temperatures will have risen by 1.5 to
four point five degrees Celsius if the
increase is near the low end 1.5 Celsius
then we're already halfway there and we
should be more able to adapt with some
regions becoming drier and less
productive but others becoming warmer
wetter are more productive on the other
hand a rise of 4.5 degrees Celsius would
be similar in magnitude to the warming
that's occurred since the last glacial
maximum 22 thousand years ago when most
of North America was under an ice sheet
two kilometers thick so that would
represent a dramatic change of climate
so it's vitally important for scientists
to predict the change in temperature
with as much precision as possible
so that society can plan for the future
the present range of uncertainty is
simply too large to be confident of how
best to respond to climate change but
this estimate of 1.5 to 4.5 Celsius for
a doubling of carbon dioxide hasn't
changed in 35 years why haven't we been
able to narrow it down the answer is
that we don't yet understand aerosols
and clouds well enough but a new
experiment at CERN is tackling the
problem in order to predict how the
temperature will change scientists need
to know something called Earth's climate
sensitivity the temperature change in
response to a radiative forcing a
radiative forcing is a temporary
imbalance between the energy received
from the Sun and the energy radiated
back out to space like the imbalance
caused by an increase of greenhouse
gases to correct the imbalance earth
warms up or cools
we can determine earth climate
sensitivity from the experiment that
we've already performed in the
industrial age since 1750 and then use
this number to determine how much more
it will warm for various projected
radiative forcings in the 21st century
to do this we need to know two things
first the global temperature rise in
1750 and second the radiative forcing of
the present day climate relative to the
pre-industrial climate for the radiative
forcings
we know that human activities have
increased greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere which have warmed the planet
but our activities have at the same time
increase the amount of aerosol particles
and clouds which have cooled the planet
pre-industrial greenhouse gas
concentrations are well measured from
bubbles trapped in ice cores obtained in
Greenland and Antarctica so the
greenhouse gas forcings are precisely
known but we have no way of directly
measuring how cloudy it was in 1750 and
that's the main source of uncertainty in
Earth's climate sensitivity to
understand when Industrial cloudiness we
must use computer models that reliably
simulate the processes responsible for
forming aerosols and clouds now to most
people aerosols are the thing that make
your hair stick but that's only one type
of aerosol atmospheric aerosols are tiny
liquid or solid particles suspended in
the air they are either primary from
dust sea spray salt or burning biomass
or secondary formed by gas to particle
conversion in the atmosphere also known
as particle nucleation aerosols are
everywhere in the atmosphere and they
can block out the Sun in polluted urban
environments or bathe distant mountains
in a blue haze more importantly a cloud
droplet cannot form without an aerosol
particle seed so without aerosol
particles
there'd be no clouds and without clouds
there be no fresh water the climate
would be much hotter and there would be
no life so we owe our existence to
aerosol particles however despite their
importance how aerosol particles for
in the atmosphere and their effect on
clouds are poorly understood even the
vapors responsible for aerosol particle
formation are not well established
because they're present in only minut
amounts near one molecule per million
million molecules of air this lack of
understanding is the main reason for the
large uncertainty in climate sensitivity
and the corresponding wide range of
future climate projections however an
experiment underway at CERN named
perhaps unsurprisingly
cloud has managed to build a steel
vessel that's large enough and has low
enough contamination that aerosol
formation can for the first time be
measured under tightly controlled
atmospheric conditions in the laboratory
in its first five years of operation
cloud has identified the vapours
responsible for aerosol particle
formation in the atmosphere which
includes sulfuric acid ammonia amines
and biogenic vapours from trees using an
ionizing particle beam from the CERN
proton synchrotron cloud is also
investigating if galactic cosmic rays
enhance the formation of aerosols and
clouds this has been suggested as a
possible unaccounted natural climate
forcing agent since the flux of cosmic
rays raining down on the atmosphere
there is with solar activity so cloud is
addressing two big questions firstly how
cloudy was the pre-industrial climate
and hence how much have clouds changed
due to human activities that knowledge
will help sharp and climate projections
in the 21st century and secondly could
the puzzling observations of solar
climate variability in the
pre-industrial climate be explained by
an influence of galactic cosmic rays on
clouds ambitious but realistic goals
when your heads in the clouds
you